[Música]
un cordial saludo mi nombre es ángela
gómez y bienvenidos a esta emisión
especiales con las buenas noticias del
año empezamos con una buena noticia para
los derechos en eeuu derecho bin el
oficial de policía que asesinó a george
floyd fue declarado culpable en abril
por los cargos de homicidio y asesinato
en segundo grado la decisión fue
recibida con beneplácito por la
comunidad afroamericana que acusó a la
policía de excesos y de racismo
andrés granadillo nos amplia
justicia para george freud estados
unidos sentenció 22 años a derek
shopping por asesinar al afroamericano
las imágenes de su muerte dieron la
vuelta al mundo en un vídeo amateur se
vio a floyd inmovilizado en el suelo
diciendo repetidamente no puedo respirar
su asaltante el policía joven lo mantuvo
con su rodilla en el cuello durante
nueve minutos y 29 segundos después
muy brevemente quiero dar mis
condolencias a la familia floyd persa
muy raro
espero que esto les dé un poco de
tranquilidad y sombra en
el violento asesinato de floyd provocó
protestas durante meses en todo eeuu
contra la brutalidad policial y la
injusticia racial personalidades
afroamericanas como los obama
reaccionaron a la condena hoy un jurado
hizo lo correcto pero la verdadera
justicia requiere mucho más
también lo hizo oprah winfrey aliviada y
emocionada de una manera que no esperaba
llore lágrimas de alegría mientras se
leía cada veredicto si en el proceso
penal sobrino reconoció a su
culpabilidad si lo hizo en el litigio
civil donde se declaró culpable por
primera vez de violar los derechos
civiles de floyd y
ciertamente hoy vimos un cierto nivel de
responsabilidad pero direct selling
también se quedó con muy pocas opciones
y se declaró culpable hoy después de
someter a esta familia a un juicio
desgarrador en el que el jurado se dio
cuenta muy rápidamente de que él era
culpable de todos los cargos
policías estadounidenses han sido
acusados de homicidio contra
afroamericanos en varias ocasiones y en
la mayoría de los casos declarados
inocentes pero este no fue el caso de
floyd donde la balanza de la justicia
estuvo de su lado
en abril se cumplieron 106 años del
genocidio contra el pueblo armenio por
el entonces imperio otomano cuyos
gobernantes turcos decretaron el
asesinato y la expulsión de más de un
millón de líderes intelectuales y
activistas y este año por primera vez un
presidente estadounidense reconoció a
las atrocidades en el aniversario de lo
ocurrido en 1915 joe biden abordó el
tema que fue evadido por sus
predecesores poniéndose del lado de los
derechos humanos
este anuncio que tiene principalmente un
valor simbólico podría debilitar la
relación de washington con el presidente
reyes tayib erdogán en ankara
el año 2021 ha tenido un despliegue sin
precedentes de las energías renovables o
energía limpia en el mundo la agencia
internacional de la energía pronosticó
que podría haber un aumento del 60 por
ciento hasta 2026 con china a la cabeza
a pesar de la buena noticia muchas
preguntas surgen es sobre cómo será el
plan energético de los países en las
próximas décadas y sobre cómo su
financiamiento informe de andrew a amaya
verde alternativa o limpia son varios
los adjetivos para hablar de la energía
renovable el último informe de la
agencia internacional de la energía
asegura que este recurso tuvo una
expansión en 2021 de un 3% respecto a
2020 con 290 gigavatios de nueva
capacidad instalada lo que supone un
récord la nueva economía global de la
energía está al alza sin embargo los
retos son grandes
para mí el punto ciego del debate
climático es el financiamiento de
energías limpias en países emergentes
cuando miramos nuestras cifras más del
80% de las emisiones en los próximos 20
años provendrán de países emergentes
además menos del 20 por ciento de las
inversiones de energías limpias se
destinan a estos países
según la agencia durante los próximos
cinco años será china el país que
encabezará la capacidad instalada de
energías renovables con el 43% del
crecimiento global seguida por europa de
eeuu e india
si bien el futuro de las energías verdes
por muchos los gobiernos deben
esforzarse más para cumplir con las
metas adoptadas en la cop 26 entre ellas
la limitación del calentamiento global a
15 grados centígrados y la neutralidad
de carbono para 2050 aunque no logremos
llegar a 1,5 grados si alcanzamos 16 o
17 grados sigue estando bien siempre es
mejor que tener un aumento de
temperatura de casi 3 grados para
alcanzar esto birol asegura que habrá
que doblar las capacidades instaladas de
energía renovable entre 2021 y 2026 y
además la demanda mundial de
biocombustibles y de calefacción
procedente de fuentes limpias tendría
que crecer hasta 4 veces más que lo
dicho en el informe en españa' ya pueden
pedir la eutanasia a quienes tengan una
enfermedad grave o incurable el 25 de
junio entró en vigencia la ley que
permite a los pacientes que padecen un
sufrimiento físico o psíquico constante
e intolerable decidir entre recibir
atención para mejorar su calidad de vida
o solicitar una muerte digna la nación
se convirtió en la séptima del mundo en
legalizar la medida que ya fue en la
cartera básica del sistema nacional de
salud y que recibirá financiación
pública
y seguimos con temas de salud del
instituto de investigación lerner de la
clínica cleveland en eeuu desarrolla una
vacuna contra el cáncer de mama los
investigadores empezaron a inscribir a
pacientes para un primer ensayo el
medicamento está diseñado para atacar el
cáncer de seno triple negativo uno de
los más agresivos
no aguantará vi es una diseñadora siria
de 29 años en 2019 le descubrieron un
cáncer de seno estaba un tratamiento de
ese entonces perdió todo su cabello no
soportaba la idea hasta que decidió
aceptar su nueva identidad en mano
muggle en chile cuando me miro en el
espejo veo a alguien fuerte pero es
cierto que tampoco me veo extraño mi
antiguo yo su halle el andar el cahuín
pero hay esperanza para ryan y millones
de mujeres a través del mundo que sufren
de cáncer de seno
una vacuna propuesta por un grupo de
científicos del instituto de
investigación lerner de la clínica
cleveland en eeuu está en desarrollo
tras 20 años de investigación la vacuna
será ensayada en mujeres que ya han sido
diagnosticadas con cáncer de mama triple
negativo uno de los más agresivos y
tratadas con diferentes tipos de
terapias en la primera fase las
voluntarias recibirán tres dosis de la
vacuna experimental una cada dos semanas
mientras se determina si hay una
respuesta inmunitaria el oncólogo tomás
bot principal investigador del proyecto
dijo a largo plazo nuestra meta es
determinar si esta vacuna es capaz de
combatir el cáncer de seno especialmente
en sus variantes más agresivas antes de
que ocurra de tener éxito podría
convertirse en una terapia preventiva
eficaz incluso para personas sanas según
cifras de la organización mundial de la
salud en 2020 2 o 3 millones de mujeres
en el mundo fueron diagnosticadas con
cáncer de mama de las cuales 685.000
fallecieron por esta enfermedad a
finales de noviembre celebró la
comunidad diversa de botsuana tras ganar
una larga batalla por despenalizar la
homosexualidad el tribunal superior
falló contra el gobierno que había
apelado la decisión histórica de 2019 la
homosexualidad estaba prohibida desde
1965 con penas de hasta 7 años de
prisión lesotho mozambique angola y
seychelles también están entre los pocos
países africanos que han despenalizado
las relaciones del mismo sexo
esta sentencia es realmente
impresionante porque va a cambiar la
vida de muchas personas en nuestro país
es realmente una oportunidad para que la
comunidad lgtb reivindiqué su humanidad
y cambie el statu quo en nuestro país en
julio argentina dio un paso en favor de
las personas no binarias el país cuyo
movimiento el gti es muy poderoso se
convirtió en la primera nación latina en
incluir una equis en el documento de
identidad de las personas que no se
identifican como femenina o masculina
este decreto se inscribe en una política
que quiere favorecer la diversidad y la
libre elección de los ciudadanos
y terminamos en la alfombra roja este
año 2021 fue particularmente prolífico
para las mujeres en el cine desde kant
hasta los ángeles en abril la academia
de los oscar dio a la china -que luisao
la estatuilla a mejor directora por no
mad land un doble reconocimiento por ser
la primera asiática y la segunda mujer
en obtener el máximo galardón la
británica emerald cn lo obtuvo mejor
guión original por una joven prometedora
filme que además se presenta un camino
de venganza contra el abuso sexual en
julio el festival de cannes premio a su
segunda mujer como mejor directora en su
historia la francesa julia dio con no se
llevó la palma de oro con titín en
septiembre otri tivo en él se llevó el
león de oro de venecia por el
acontecimiento y en septiembre alina
greek orégano la concha de oro en san
sebastián a por blue moon
siga con nosotros en france 24
[Música]